26 pays réunis pendant trois jours à
voisins le bretonneux le club skipping
organise au gymnase des pyramides le sky
par att french open les compétitions
handisport avec des têtes d'affiché
mondiale c'est une première on n'a pas
fait de tournée en france depuis 2014 où
ça s'était pas très bien passé et on
fait avec paris 2024 on devait faire un
tournoi en france et là c'est si on va
dire un des premiers tournois sachant
que je pense que si ça se passe très
bien les gens voudront venir et là il ya
des très très bon joueur la compétition
permet de proposer les onze classes
différentes présent dans le tennis de
table handisport en tennis de table il
ya onze classes différentes il faut bien
comprendre que selon que nous sommes en
fauteuil ou que nous avons un déficit
mental il se passe pas du tout la même
chose heures une table on se place
différentes qui permettent de répartir
ses joueurs de façon à équilibrer un
petit peu les compétitions en parallèle
pendant ces trois jours de tournoi le
rendez-vous permet également une
vingtaine de classes de saint quentin en
yvelines de découvrir le tennis de table
handisport quand des jeunes viennent
leur regard du coût change sur le
handicap et sur leur capacité quand ils
seront plus grands à faire en sorte
d'accueillir la diversité donc pour eux
on a imaginé un événement et d un
parcours qui leur permet de voir les
matches mais aussi de se mettre en
situation la compétition se poursuivra
jusqu'à ce jeudi 11 novembre si vous
voulez assister à ce rendez vous
l'événement est ouvert gratuitement aux
spectateurs
[Applaudissements]